Robert and Kim Johnson Herjavec are two
glowing newlyweds he caught up with the
couple at an Emmy reception in LA Monday
night getting the scoop on their new
life together changing my name like
that's kind of a little bit of getting
used to but I like it you know in some
ways it feels no different in other ways
it is different but not it's just the
same yeah it's funny that it does feel
different in some ways but it's so the
same I think we're still in a high back
from the honeymoon it was just the best
having all of our family and friends in
town for the wedding and then going away
it's just been the most incredible kind
of month as for what's next for the
Dancing with the Stars alums I love the
show and I'd love to still be part of it
but um you know I want to sort of hang
out my dad shoes and what a way to ends
it's like Thank You Dancing with the
Stars I can dance with somebody else so
I can win the Mirrorball back at work
and we start filming season eight
for the first time ever we're gonna have
six sharks at once yeah I just I don't
know why I remember that I was in my
press briefing